one important way the teachers can
enhance a growth mindset is to really
help students self reflect on their own
learning so in the learn storm
activities we tried to be really
intentional about creating a lot of room
for students to engage in
self-reflection and one of our goals in
doing that was to really kind of help
teachers create that really self
reflective environment and really got
the school year started that way and
hopefully that's something that can be
then carried forward for the rest of the
school year it can be really easy to
learn a bunch of stuff and not realize
that you're learning it in the absence
of self reflection so and self
reflection could really help us
recognize what we're doing can help us
connect it to to why we're doing it I
could really help us internalize more
deeply certain ideas when teachers help
students reflect on their own learning
they can think about well what are what
are the goals they have for their
learning and then when as they're going
through and accomplishing their those
goals if students are self reflecting on
that and they're seeing those goals as a
part of being on a growth trajectory
that'll help them get to whether it's a
good grade or becoming a better writer
or or a better mathematician that's
ultimately more motivating for students
and it really helps them see really see
that they're making progress on that
trajectory which is a lot more
motivating they're just kind of taking
off things that don't really seem to be
that related to each other I think one
particularly important kind of
self-reflection is when when students
hear teachers or hear themselves or hear
their peers self reflect on the ways
that struggles help them improve it can
be a really good a good and a really
good reminder that struggles aren't kind
of the endpoint of something that
doesn't struggle doesn't mean that you
should give up and that you're not cut
out to do something but in the contrary
that if we use the right kinds of
strategies and we persist and maybe if
we get help from others and we can
overcome strategies and become better
better learners or better mathematicians
or better at whatever better
skateboarders may be better at whatever
the task might be